- You've gotta speak up.
This thing about
dropping our voice,
you know, I used to go into
movie studios for meetings
and I'd be sitting out
in the waiting room,
you know, you sit for a few
minutes before they call you in,
and almost every time,
somebody would come up to me
and drop his voice and say,
"Oi, I saw you on 'Hannity.'
I saw you on 'Beck.'"
And I would always
say the same thing.
"Why are you whispering?
(Dave laughs)
We're in the right."
And like, (laughs)
and I understand the fear-
- Right, right.
- and I understand,
you know, we famously had this
supposedly secret organization,
the Friends of Abe
out in Hollywood.
And I kept saying to
the leaders, you know,
"We've gotta go public."
And they wouldn't do it
'cause they didn't want the
working guys to get caught.
The gaffers and the guys
who were not movie stars
and all this.
But I just thought if you don't,
if you act in secret, then
you look like you're ashamed.
And if you act in secret,
you look like you're afraid.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is a prolific screenwriter,
a host at The Daily Wire,
a multi-time author, and
author of the brand new book,
"When Christmas Comes."
Andrew Klavan, welcome
back to "The Rubin Report."
- Good to see you,
Dave, how are you?
- I am just fine.
I feel that we have to just
get some stuff out of the way,
right up top though
because last I saw you
was here at my house.
I had a dinner party right
before you made your exitus
and left California,
left Los Angeles,
and it was a wonderful
evening, Michael Knowles,
several other, you
know, far-right figures.
And we were going around the
table and you wanted whiskey.
And I said, "No, no, I want
you to try this tequila."
And you said, "No,
no, I like whiskey."
And I demanded that
you try the tequila.
And then an hour later,
you admitted to me
you just didn't
like the tequila.
And I've been sitting on
this for like six months.
I feel bad about this,
you know what I mean?
It was you're going away thing.
Sure, you abandoned me here,
but I made you drink
tequila and I feel bad.
You're a whiskey guy.
- You know, I'm a
creature of habit.
What can I tell you?
I discovered Macallan
12 many years ago
and the guy at the store,
I lived in England,
and every week, I'd
go in and the guy say,
"You have to try
something else."
And I try something else.
I think, "Yeah, I really
liked that Macallan 12."
And I go back the
next week, he say,
"You gotta try something else."
That went on for about three
months and finally, I said,
"You know, Macallan
12 is the best."
And the guy said,
"Yeah, you're right."
(Dave laughs)
I thought if I like
it, I stick with it.
- You conservatives,
you love whiskey.
Now, I know I'm
the new guy here.
I would consider myself
sort of a new
school conservative,
but I bring tequila in,
it freaks people out.
You guys, it's all about
whiskey for you people.
- Yeah, the tequila is just a
little edgy for us, you know?
I mean, whiskey, we know where
we're going with whiskey.
We're going straight
down the tubes. (laughs)
Great time.
And it goes well with steak,
which we're also very big on.
Steak and cigars and
whiskey are really perfect.
- Yes, you are all
men, it's very obvious.
You're men and you're-
- Yeah, yeah.
That's it.
- doing your thing.
All right, so you
did leave me here.
You've been gone for what?
About six months now.
Life is good for you.
- Yup.
- You're happy.
You've left.
Nothing good is happening
here, fair to say.
- Fair to say.
I turned Virginia,
I single-handedly
turned Virginia red.
(Dave laughs)
(Andrew laughs)
I moved, when I
moved to Virginia
and because it's kind of
between The Daily Wire
and my publishing
life in New York and,
you know, within months,
I just managed to,
I'm Spartacus.
I just said, you know, "All
right, follow me everybody.
We're gonna turn this state."
And they rushed into
the voting booth
and now, we're a red state.
- So for real, what was it
like for those couple of weeks
before the election?
And then that night,
I mean, it was really,
I think, a huge moment if
we're gonna get any wins.
I think that was the
one that we needed.
I had been saying it for weeks.
That's the one-
- Yup.
keep an eye on this one,
and it actually happened.
And I think a lot of
people have hope now.
- Well, you know,
it's interesting.
When I got to Virginia, I
live in Northern Virginia,
which is the liberal, the
blue part of Virginia.
And several people
have said to me,
"Oh, boy, this is a
really liberal place.
This is really left wing."
And I was looking around and
having come from Los Angeles,
I was thinking, "You
know, not really so much.
It's not the same thing."
There are a lot of
military people,
a lot of people
who are Democrats
in the old kind of
sense of the word
that yes, they want a welfare
state or some kind of,
you know, normal thing that
two people might argue about
around the 50-yard line
as they used to say,
but it was not
that crazy LA thing
where any idea that comes out,
"Oh yeah, men are women now."
Okay, that's good.
You know, everybody,
we're racist.
Everyone's racist.
Oh, so we gotta teach
children to be racist.
Yeah, good idea.
This is like a
normal American state
with Democrats and
Republicans in it.
And when they found out,
"Oh, you know, we're
teaching your children
that it's okay to be a pedophile
or actually the
object of pedophilia.
- Yeah.
- It's okay to hate people
'cause they're White or
they're Black people.
We're like, "I'm sorry, what?"
You know, where
did that come from?
We're in LA, people just go
like lemmings off the cliff.
In Virginia, not so much.
It was very tense.
I thought it should
have been 80% to 20%.
It was only two or
three percentage points.
And to be honest with you,
I was worried about the
kind of Trump contingent.
You know, I'm good friends
with Sebastian Gorka
who just loves Donald Trump,
and he was picking on Youngkin.
I was saying to him, "You
know, it's a purple state.
You know, we're not gonna
get everything we want."
But Youngkin was a talented guy
and because of Trump, I think,
because of Trump, he understood
that he had to fight
the culture war.
That you don't fight the
culture where you can't win.
You don't fight over abortion,
you don't fight over marriage.
You fight, but to fight
teaching racism in school.
Yeah, you can do that.
And so I think that Donald
Trump taught him something,
but he managed to excite
the Trump contingent
without linking himself
to Donald Trump.
And in fact, there was
one hilarious story
that when Trump,
troll that he is,
said he was coming to Virginia,
Youngkin's people
called him up and said,
"No, no, don't come
to Virginia." (laughs)
So he really found the
right note as we didn't
in the recall in California.
- Yup.
- And that's exciting
because it means,
you know, Ronald
Reagan said, basically,
and this is a paraphrase, but
he said, "Republicans fail
when they turn out not to
be who they said they were.
Democrats fail when
they turn out to be
who they say they are."
And then they go too
far all the time.
And so right this minute,
when Democrats are being
everything they say,
and they're ruining everything,
everything they touch goes bad.
This is a good moment.
It's a good moment
to remind people
that a little bit
of common sense,
a little bit of good business,
a little bit of family life,
you know, it's not
such a bad thing.
And you can build
a very nice country
and a very nice life off that.
- Wait, are you saying
that the people on MSNBC
who told me that it was all
because of those middle America
white supremacist women?
That's what they were saying.
It's all the women
who are always voting
in white supremacists.
Are you saying that joy Reid
is not telling me the truth?
(Andrew laughs)
- We got this
lieutenant governor
who's a gun-toting black
lady who was in the Marines
and it's like, and
everybody, this is the thing,
everybody loves her.
And they're telling us,
"Oh yeah, but she
is white supremacy.
This is the mark
of white supremacy
when you vote for a black person
who doesn't agree with us."
- Yeah.
- And so at some point,
you just gotta hope that
there's enough common sense
and courage in the
American people
where they stand up to that
because it's not
just common sense.
A lot of people I know,
including Democrats
are saying to me,
"You know, this
woke stuff is bad.
There's something
wrong with this."
But you also have
to have courage
because they will
throw you off Twitter.
They will throw
you off Facebook.
They might get you
fired from your job,
they might get you canceled.
So you gotta have
the courage to say,
you know, out loud,
"We don't want this."
And what they did in Virginia
was they attacked people's kids.
And that will turn a lot
of moms and a lot of dads
into very brave people.
You know, you get the
mama and papa bears
will just rip your head off
before they let you
ruin their kids.
- So as a guy that spent,
I think you spent a couple
decades here in crazy LA, right?
- Yup, yup.
- How long were you here for?
- Well, I was only in LA for
seven years, but I was in,
before that, I was in
Santa Barbara for 15 years.
So all in all,
I got the California
experience for two decades.
- So as a guy that
was around that,
and also was around
Hollywood and doing movies,
and Clint Eastwood, although
he's one of the few sane ones
we've got-
- Yeah.
- but you've been
around the machine.
What is it?
Have you been able
to really unpack
maybe now that you've
stepped away from it?
Like what is it that
causes that group
think amongst these people,
who so often seemingly vote
against their own interests?
They cannot be happy
that the homeless people
are now climbing up
the Hollywood Hills
like we're in "Walking Dead."
- No, it is absolutely true,
but there's certain things,
there certainly breaks
walls between them.
For instance, in San Francisco,
the rich people are
living in Silicon Valley.
You know, the rich people
are not living in the places
that they let go down the drain.
There is, you know, it's a
funny thing because in a way,
in a way, it's a
point that Marx,
Karl Marx himself might've made.
You know, Karl Marx
basically believed
that your wages had not got,
you hadn't become richer
if there was now a
bigger divide between you
and the really rich people.
He believed that it was
all relative, you know?
So even though you
were doing better,
if the next guy was
doing 10 times better,
you were gonna be unhappy.
And there's a lot of
human truth to that.
I mean, that's, it's
envy, it's covetousness.
Those are just human traits.
And so we have got a moment now
when some of these wealthy
people are so wealthy,
and so detached,
and so surrounded by other
people like themselves,
and so disdainful of the
ordinary men and women
who just wanna do their
jobs and have some fun
and get married and have kids.
They're so distasteful
of that life
that they really have no idea
what people are talking about.
Some of these people
who are accusing,
look, I've lived out of the
country for seven years.
This is the least
racist country on Earth.
It is the least racist
country on Earth.
And when they talk
about systemic racism,
it's the least systemic
racist country on Earth.
'Cause obviously, there are
always gonna be racist people,
but they don't know it.
They don't know it.
When they talk about,
"Oh yeah, these people
are just racist."
They believe it because
they never see them.
They never meet them,
they never talk to them,
they never listen to them.
Some of the stuff that
you and I talk about
on what is now called
conservative media,
they've never heard.
They have never heard it.
And when they discover it,
they're absolutely shocked.
I mean, Russell
Brand, the comedian,
- Yeah, yeah.
- He was a very bright guy,
but he is kind of
left to center.
When he found out that the
Russian collusion thing
was a hoax, he went on
the air and he said,
"I'm gobsmacked, I'm
flabbergasted. Who knew?"
Well, we knew.
You know, we knew and
we said it all the time,
and a lot of stuff that we know
ultimately becomes mainstream,
but they never stop and say,
"Oh gee, the right-wingers
were telling the truth,
and the New York Times and
CNN and NBC were all lying."
They just never say that.
Think of all the people
that they made into idols,
Andrew Cuomo, you know,
what was the other
guy's, Michael Avenatti.
- You know.
- Yup.
- Was that his name, yeah?
- Yup, yup.
- And now, Dr. Fauci,
torturing dogs,
having eating the
faces of dogs. (laughs)
- Literally, like you
cannot make this stuff up.
Eating the faces of dogs
(Andrew laughs)
that they don't let
their paws go to,
I mean, it's just insane.
- And these are their heroes.
And, you know, you'd think
at some point they would say,
"Hmm, maybe we're not that
good a judge of character.
You know, maybe we ought
to take another look at it.
At Ted Cruz, maybe
he's not a bad guy.
You know, maybe
picking on Mike Pence
for being true to his wife
isn't really a
great look for us."
They never do, they
never listen to us,
they're so separated.
They're so sequestered
by their wealth
and their cultural power
more than anything else.
Their cultural power
has sequestered them
that they do not know
what they do not know
and that's basically the kind
of stuff that the rest of us
are talking about.
You and I don't
agree on everything.
Me and Ben Shapiro don't
agree and Michael Knowles.
We all have these big arguments.
We have a range of
opinions on the right.
They've just got
this one opinion,
but they hear it again
and again and again
and they think
everything else is evil.
- So what's the trick?
I mean, you know, when I do my
weekly Q and A's on Thursday,
there's always like 10
questions of the same variety
which is what are the
tricks to wake up my friend?
How can I bring them back?
I can't get them to sit down
and watch a PragerU video
or Dave, now you're
too scary for them.
So I assume you're on the
scary list too, Andrew.
Like what are the tricks?
You got any tricks?
I mean, you were around
a lot of these people.
- Yeah, two things,
very important.
One is you've gotta speak up.
This thing about
dropping our voice.
You know, I used to go into
movie studios for meetings
and I'd be sitting out
in the waiting room,
you sit for a few minutes
before they call you in,
and almost every time,
somebody would come up to me
and drop his voice and say,
"Oi, I saw you on 'Hannity.'
I saw you on 'Beck.'"
And I would always
say the same thing.
"Why are you whispering?
(Dave laughs)
We're in the right." (laughs)
And like-
- Right.
- And I understand the
fear, and I understand,
you know, we famously had this
supposedly secret organization,
The Friends of Abe
out in Hollywood.
And I kept saying
to the leaders,
"You know, we've
gotta go public."
And they wouldn't do it
'cause they didn't want the
working guys to get caught.
The gaffers and the guys
who were not movie stars
and all this.
But I just thought,
if you don't,
if you act in secret, then
you look like you're ashamed.
And if you act in secret,
you look like you're afraid.
And so all of us,
because all of us,
you know, it's not just artists
who are part of the culture,
it's not just media people.
Everybody is part
of the culture.
Everybody has a
little piece of it
like a candle in their hand.
You have got to speak up,
You've got to.
You gotta say it politely,
you don't have to
scream at people,
get in their faces,
you don't have to
be Donald Trump.
You just politely say,
"You know, I disagree."
And if we don't
start doing that,
if we let them cowl
us and silence us,
we have no choice, chance.
And the other side of
it also is (chuckles)
right when you just think that
the truth is so important,
the facts are so important
that you don't have
to be nice about them,
that you can scream an ugly
truth in someone's face.
And Paul Simon said,
"You know, I don't
want you to lie to me,
but I want some tenderness
beneath your honesty."
And right-wingers got
to learn that trick
because the left are ugly.
They're mean, they
call people names,
they're disgusting, they
cancel people, they bully them.
If we don't have a sort
of civilized attitude,
when I say civilized,
that doesn't mean
keeping your mouth shut.
It means speaking bravely
and clearly in a polite way,
then we're just
the same as them.
We get lost in the crowd.
So if we don't develop
some communication skills
and some courage, we'll be lost.
We'll be swept away
'cause they own the media.
- You know, it's so funny
because I obviously
agree with the sentiment,
and then there's this
part of me as someone
that's sort of new to this
thing on the right, let's say,
that when you see them
lie and lie and lie again,
and know they're lying,
and we know they're lying,
and everyone knows
salt units in quote,
and they just keep going,
I can somehow see how
decent right wing people
that are moderates, really,
start sounding like
crazy, angry kooks
because the years go by,
you try to rationalize,
you try to be open, you
try to have conversations,
they keep lying, things
keep getting worse,
they're dragging you
to hell with them,
next thing you know, you're
screaming on the radio
for four hours a day about
whatever it might be.
So I'm sympathetic to, even
though I get your point,
I am sympathetic to the people
that it sort of sound like
they're nuts at some level.
- Me too, and they
also gaslight you.
So for 30 years,
they call you racist,
they call you sexist,
your god stinks,
your country stinks,
your history stinks,
everything about you stinks.
Then Rush Limbaugh comes
on the air and he says,
"Well, these feminazis,"
and everybody goes,
"Where is the civility?
- Yeah.
What has happened to the
civility in this country?"
So they gaslight you,
but if you listen,
one of the things
that happened to me
when I came back from
England, where I was living,
I started listening to Rush
just to hear what
the fuss was about,
and he was so happy and so funny
and so, kind of sweet-natured.
With all the stuff that
he said that I thought,
"No, wait a minute.
All the stuff I heard is untrue
and I wanna listen to
what this guy has to say."
They called him uncivil
and he could sometimes
go off, obviously,
but he was actually
a happy warrior.
And he was a wonderfully
funny and warm person.
When you, the one time I
talked to him in person,
he was kind of shy and
sweet-natured and all that.
It was kind of a shock.
But still, he had
a knack for that.
So you're absolutely right.
I have total sympathy
for why people do it.
I know why they
supported Donald Trump.
I told people who were
appalled by Donald Trump,
"You know, think of them
as the voice of people
who have been just
insulted for 50 years."
- Mm-hmm.
- You know, that's what he is.
That's why they came up with
him and he had his flaws.
I think they really
hurt him in the end,
but they also helped
them get where he was,
and they made people love
him 'cause he spoke for them.
But I think we need,
you know, the thing I liked
about this guy in Virginia,
Glenn Youngkin, is
he is civilized,
he's direct, but he
says what he has to say.
And I think that that's
really the trick.
I think it's the
trick for all of us.
Because if ordinary
people aren't speaking,
we seem like we're afraid and
we seem like we're ashamed.
- Yeah. And since you brought
up Trump, I will credit you.
I've credited you
many times for this,
but on election night 2016 and
I was not voting for Trump,
I voted for Gary Johnson,
but I was with you,
Daily Wire guys,
everyone drinking whiskey,
and the results came in,
everybody was shocked,
but you said something
to me that really,
I think lit a fire under me
about the state of the world
which was that, "Look what
just happened in America."
The thing that nobody said-
- Yup.
was gonna happen, that
everyone said couldn't happen,
it just happened.
And that is the true
beauty of America.
That's what we sort of seem to
be forgetting at the moment.
- You know, it's one of,
I have this conversation,
especially with conservatives.
Conservatives have a knack.
It's a natural thing,
and it's one of the reasons
they are conservative
is they can trace any
change to disaster.
(Dave laughs)
So whatever changes, it's like,
"Oh yeah, well, this is
gonna knock over that domino,
and then the wall fall down.
And once the wall falls down,
the savages come in
and we're all dead."
You know, (laughs) we
do this all the time,
but just because having
been around so long,
I've seen a lot of stuff.
So I saw New York
when it was a cesspit,
like it's becoming again today.
- Yup.
- And I thought,
"This is the end of New York."
And no, Giuliani came in.
One man came in.
They called him racist
every single day of
his administration,
and he turned it into the most
beautiful city in the world,
the best city in the
world for about 20 years
with the help of Bloomberg,
who kept it that way.
And now, they've just driven
it back into the ground.
The same was true
with the country.
The country in the '70s and
'80s was in a terrible state.
I mean, people were
just so unhappy
and they gas lines
to get gasoline,
just like it is today with the
inflation and all this stuff,
all coming back.
And Ronald Reagan came in
and said, "You know what?
I'm gonna cut taxes,
we're gonna change that,
and we're gonna end,
by the way, we're gonna
win the cold war."
And people today say,
"Well, it wasn't Reagan.
You know, it was
this, it was that."
He was the only
person who said that.
I mean, everybody else, all
the intellectuals were like,
"What do you mean?"
And Reagan said, "I
mean we win, they lose."
And so all of these things
can change in a heartbeat,
but they don't change
if people hide.
They do not change if people
will not make that change.
I mean my parents,
lifelong Democrats
'til the day they died,
they voted for Giuliani
the second time-
- Hah.
- because they said,
"You know, oh, the city was
terrible, and now it's nice."
You know? (laughs)
And if we don't have at
least that much common sense,
it's hard to make those change.
But it's true.
As long as we still have
an operational democracy
and we can get the word out
in Facebook, in Twitter,
and all these people are
not censoring us completely,
you'd be shocked
at what can happen.
- So I wanna talk
to you a little bit
about where faith
falls into this
'cause you have a
really interesting,
we've discussed it a
couple of times publicly,
a really interesting journey
of faith for yourself,
personally,
but I think it also does
frame a lot of your politics.
And I've sort of come to the
conclusion that in many ways,
my frustration with the
last sort of sane liberals
is that they've disconnected
everything from faith.
Thus, they end up in this
constant political fight,
trying to find
meaning in something
that can offer no meaning.
And I do find that very
different than conservatives
who don't find their
salvation in politics.
I don't think that
politics is everything
or that the culture
war is everything
or that the here and
now is everything.
And I think that the sort of
last libs, they kind of do.
I think Jordan Peterson
was really trying to
move that for them.
And I don't know that
it quite got there yet.
- Yeah.
- Take that away.
There's the statement, run.
- I mean, I love Jordan,
I know you love Jordan.
I think he gets
caught sometimes in
what I call the
reason trap, you know?
The reason is a wonderful thing.
It is a wonderful
way of figuring out
the reasonable
part of the world,
but there is a part of the world
that's extraordinarily
important and goes beyond that,
which is the inner
human experience.
The inner experience of just
being here, which is reason,
emotion, love, all the things
that make life worthwhile.
You know, that actually work.
And it's in that place
where you start to sense
after a while that,
"Oh, you know, it's
not that I can prove."
Here's the leap of faith for me.
I can't prove that it's
better to give a beggar bread
than to torture a
child to death for fun.
I can't prove that,
you can't prove it.
There's no place of
reason where you can say,
"Gee, if you enjoy
torturing a child to death,
why not do it?
But you know, you know,
the same way that you know
that your father should be just,
that your mother
should be tender,
you know that it is
better to do one thing
than it is to do another.
That is already supernatural
in the sense that
physical actions,
natural actions
have a meaning above themselves.
That's a supernatural thing.
Literally, when I
say supernatural,
I mean literally above nature.
- Yup, yup, I got it.
- And if there is something
that is better than
something else,
then there is something
toward which attends.
There is an ultimate good,
you know, something that
is the measure of all good,
a sovereign good.
And if there's a sovereign good,
it has to be a consciousness
because only conscious,
free consciousness
can choose good.
A hurricane is
neither good or evil.
It may do bad things,
but it's not doing
them for moral reasons.
So it makes sense.
If we believe, if we take,
it's not even a leap of faith,
it's kind of a little
hop of faith, you know?
Where you just say,
"If we believe that
some things are good
and some things are not as good,
we have to invest in that."
And once you do,
once you do, the whole
thing starts to make sense.
Suddenly, you say like,
"Oh, I just had to
affirm what I believe,
what I knew was true."
And I always tell people,
"Don't believe what
you don't believe."
So if somebody says to me,
you know, "Well, Rachel
Levine is really a woman."
I think like, "Yeah,
you don't believe that.
I don't believe that."
You know, Ben Shapiro
can put on a cowboy hat,
he's not a cowboy.
(Dave and Andrew laughs)
- We've seen him
with a cowboy hat.
He's not a cowboy.
- He's not a cowboy.
The only difference is
Ben will tell you that.
- Yeah.
- But,
so you know Rachel Levine is
not a woman, so why say it?
What is the benefit
you're getting
from believing something
you don't believe?
No one believes.
No one believes that
morality is relative.
No one believes it.
You believe it until
somebody punches your kid.
Then you know that no,
you know, there are certain
things that are moral.
And once you have a
worldview that makes sense,
you kind of relax into the fact
that there is something
beyond yourself
and something beyond this
petty fight that we're in,
and it makes it easier
to kind of love your neighbor
a little bit, you know?
And the joy that comes
with that is intense.
It is an amazing thing
simply to make sense,
simply to live in
life and say like,
"Yeah, that makes sense, and
this doesn't make sense,"
'cause you have a standard
by which to judge it.
For me, it became
Christianity at first
because I thought all my values
are coming out of this book.
But now, I sort of see
that Christianity is the,
it's the faith of the
word that what we are,
that what you and I are, is
we are of kind of language.
It's not like we're a
body with a soul inside
like Casper, the friendly ghost,
just floating around and inside,
you know, inside Dave,
there's the real Dave,
this invisible Dave is.
It's not that at all.
It's that you are a
word that speaks, Dave.
And that, that Dave is an
idea in the mind of God
as it were, you know?
And so, and that, once
you understand that,
then everything that you do
becomes kind of beautiful.
It all becomes a work of art.
If I give a beggar bread,
I'm not just giving
a beggar bread,
I'm actually doing
something good,
you know, in this
supernatural realm.
It's incredibly liberating.
It is an incredibly
liberating, joyful way to live.
And when I say joy,
I don't mean you walk
around happy all the time.
That would be crazy.
But I mean, as you live
life with a new gusto
because just like
when you watch a movie
and there's a sad scene in
the movie and you're crying,
you still love the
movie, you know?
And life kind of
becomes like that.
You start,
because you start to see it
has a meaning beyond itself.
And so even when you're tense
and things are going badly,
and even when you're grieving,
you understand that there
is this beauty to it.
This beauty of creation
that's going on all the time.
And it's the creation of you.
It's creation of your soul
becoming more and more of
what it's supposed to be.
So yes, to go back
to what you said,
I just totally agree that
when I see these guys
telling me that, "Oh, you know,
if only everybody will agree
I'm a woman when I'm a man,
if only everybody
will agree that
you're only hating
me because I'm Black
even though I'm holding
you up with a gun.
You know, if only
everybody will agree
to support the lie that
gives me self-respect,
that lie will become the truth."
You know, you're sad for them,
but you're not even
tempted to pretend to agree
and that's just liberating.
It's free.
- So how do we connect
some of what you just said
right there to politics?
'Cause as you were saying
it, I was thinking,
"Man, you know?"
And I've thought this many times
when I was on tour with
Jordan that that rough message
basically is what we have
to get across to people
to live more flourishing lives,
and yet we're arguing about
3.5 trillion equals zero
in boys or girls and
all of those things,
like we're not even doing
like a semi good job
of connecting, like
meaning to politics.
And that seems to me-
- Yeah.
- to be the biggest
problem right now.
- Man, I could not
agree with you more.
And I think the
left does do this.
They just do it for bad ideas.
You know, the left
does make a moral,
we're always sitting around
with a pointer saying,
"You'll make much more money."
And this Ayn Rand mentality
where we think money is
everything is so untrue
and it's left are, the people
who wanna follow us empty
and wandering,
and the left comes along
and says, "No, it's right.
It's good to believe
these stupid things
that we're telling you."
To me, the connection
with politics,
and there's no, I don't believe
there's Christian politics.
I believe that a
Christian person can be
in a range of politics as
long as he's not oppressive
and dishonest and evil.
He can have a range of politics.
But to me, at the
core of Christianity
is something I call
the great speculation.
And the great
speculation is this;
that your inner life
is as important to you
as mine is to me.
That's the great speculation.
And that's true whether
you're a garbage man,
whether you're a homemaker,
whether you're a dancer, singer,
whatever you are, the
speculation is that
your inner life is
as important to you
and as real to you and as
urgent to you as mine is to me.
And once you come to that,
once you take that guess,
first of all, you begin
to see that it's true.
You begin to realize
that people have a
right to be left alone.
They have a right to live out
the meaning of their lives,
you know?
And when they do that,
when you commit to that,
then you want them to be free.
And when you want them to
be free, you start to think,
"Well, what are the
conditions of freedom?"
You know, obviously, some of
the conditions of freedom are,
you know, have to
do with morality.
You can't murder people.
You can't steal from people.
You can't defraud them.
You can't lie about them.
Those are the 10 commandments.
That's where they come in.
You know, these are things that,
these are rules that are not
made so you'll be a nice guy.
You know, like don't do
that or we'll punish you.
That's not why they're made.
They're made to liberate
you so that you can be free.
Every one of the founders,
John Adams said it best,
but every one of
the founders said,
"This is a constitution for a
moral and religious people."
Not just moral, but a
moral and religious people.
And the reason for that
is you start to understand
that the other guy's freedom
is as important to him,
you know, as yours is.
Sometimes I hear people
talking and they'll say,
"Well..."
You know, for instance,
Black Lives Matter.
Black Lives Matter has cost
thousands of Black lives.
It's gotten thousands
of Black people killed.
Their attacks on the police
have made the Black
neighborhoods more unsafe.
Children are being
shot by random gunmen.
It's a nightmare
what they've done.
And yet they continue to do it
because they have an
idea that it's good.
If for a moment it
occurred to them
that these actual Black lives
that they are ending
with their policies
are just as important to
the people who have them
as their life is to them,
maybe their policies
would start to seem
less important to them.
And without religion, without
that great speculation,
which is a religious idea,
the idea that your neighbors
is worthy of love as you are,
without that speculation,
it's so easy to get involved
in your ideas and the goodness,
you know, "Oh yes, we
must bring justice.
And therefore, we're gonna
kill who gets in our way."
Which is part of, that's
another part of Karl Marx.
He basically said, "Yes,
terror and killing is fine
as long as you get to the
place you have to get."
- So do you think
then, to that end,
that people are believers,
whether they believe it or not?
I think that's an idea
that Jordan's been
talking a lot about lately
and I've sort of come
to that conclusion
that you end up saying,
"No, no, I'm purely secular.
I just believe in this
and we can just order
society this way."
But that in and of itself
is a type of belief
that's then driving
your decisions.
- Right, because this is
the power of narrative.
This is another thing the
left knows about more than us.
You know, it's like
we live in a time
when it's uncouth to say,
"Well, you know, let's see
what God's, let's consult God.
Let's see what God's will is.
Let's see if this is a
demonic path we're saying."
We don't say those
things anymore.
And there's a good
reason for it,
but that good reason
has become outdated.
The good reason is science.
You know, when lightning
used to strike,
they used to think that demons
were sending the lightening
so they would ring
the church bells
to chase the lightning away.
That meant the monk had
to climb up (laughs)
to the highest part of the
church and ring the bell.
And of course, he'd be hit by
lightning and killed, right?
And when Benjamin Franklin
put a lightning rod
on top of the steeple,
it was much safer,
but it also was kind of a symbol
of a materialistic philosophy
that was going to replace
the spiritual philosophy.
And now, it's actually
called the science.
That's a different word
to the Wizard of Oz.
You know, it's like-
- Yeah.
- 'cause they come and worship
the science.
For a while, it made
sense for people to say,
"Oh, all of our
speculations about demons,
and about supernatural,
and all these words that we
don't like to use anymore,
we're all wrong."
But that's not true anymore.
Science has now
progressed to a point
where we see it's not
actually as mechanical
as we thought it's gonna be.
It's kind of weird.
And it shouldn't be here.
It looks, by logic, like
life shouldn't be here,
creation shouldn't be here,
we shouldn't be able
to understand creation,
and all those things are true.
And so it's time we
stopped doing that
because you're, I think
you're absolutely right.
People believe whether
they wanna believe or not.
And it's one of the reasons
that when you let
go of that belief,
people become evil, you know?
They start to teach children
to be willing victims
of pedophilia,
they start to teach
you about race.
Those are wicked things to do.
As you know, those are
wicked things to do
because they've let go
of that sovereign good
that is the living God.
And in a way, if you
listen to the way we talk,
we don't even say, "I
was happy" anymore.
We say, "I had an
adrenaline rush."
We use these materialist
terms all the time.
We don't say, "Oh,
that's right,"
because it's obviously right.
We always have these kind of
evolutionary explanations,
and we ask what is
somebody's game theory also,
none of which makes
any sense by the way,
but leave that,
be that as it may,
we eat, we're all materialists.
And so,
and yet we know we don't
live in a materialist world.
We sense it, we feel it,
we're born with the
knowledge of it.
Like I said, there's
no evolutionary reason
why we should know our fathers
should be just, you know?
But why do we expect
our fathers to be just?
And yet when they are not just,
we know they have failed
at some essential task.
So we all know it,
but we have gotten caught
up in this narrative,
this materialist narrative
that I think is out of date.
I just think,
I think people who are
living in the 20th century
to really, and in
the 21st century,
a lot of scientific
paths have shown
that they can't explain this
without a consciousness
coming first.
The only thing
they have to admit
is that consciousness
comes before matter,
and I think that's
an obvious truth.
- You're saying I shouldn't
light my Anthony Fauci candle
every night before bed?
(Andrew laughs)
Is that what you're telling me?
He's not some sort
of saint, that man?
The highest paid person
in the federal government?
- If you just want to watch it
burn and melt,
(Andrew laughs)
I can understand why you might
wanna just watch it melt,
you know, it's like that's
for the dogs. (laughs)
- But what does it also, what
does that tell you though
about the psychological
makeup, I suppose,
of groups where it's
like we see these people
that get so much
wrong consistently,
and now, we have the
video footage to prove it.
Fauci saying one thing
about masks publicly,
another thing to
his friend about,
"Oh no, you can go on vacation
and don't worry about masks
'cause you'll touch
your face more,"
or the vaccines mean
we're gonna open up.
Now, they don't really work
and you still can transmit.
Everybody knows the million
examples that I can use here,
but a certain percentage
of people keep going to it.
They keep going, "Oh,
well I forgot it."
I don't like it. Is
it a memory issue?
Is it like, what is it?
What is it about humans?
- You know, there's
a line in (mumbles)
and I can't quote
it from memory,
but the line is something like,
"When you make people free,
when you set people free,
their first order of business
is to find something to
bow down to." (laughs)
- Right.
- I think,
you know, we're
made to love God.
We are made to bow down to God.
And I think that, you know,
after a while, after you live
the religious life a while,
you start to realize that all
your attachments to things
and to people are
pathways to God.
You know, they're not, they're
symbolic of the love of God.
Your love for your
father is love of God.
Your love for your mother
is the love of the
feminine side of God.
All these things that
you're looking for,
that people fail you in,
are because they cannot be
the perfect thing you're
looking for beyond them.
And once you attach yourself
to that perfect
thing beyond them,
it becomes so much
easier to love
the imperfect people
with their flaws
and forgive them for
the ways they can't be
with they can never be.
And so, you know, guys
like Fauci are there
because people are just
desperate for that thing,
and no one will give
it to, and by the way,
when I talk about this, when
I talk about being religious,
I think our churches
have failed us utterly.
You know, almost all of our
churches have failed us utterly.
So don't think that I'm saying,
"Oh yeah, you gotta go down
and follow that priest."
I mean, personally,
I think we should,
I'm lucky I found a great
new church that I love.
But personally, I
think a lot of people
should just start to gather
together in their homes
and start from the beginning
because our churches have
really abandoned the plot.
- So linking some of
this stuff together,
I just spoke a
couple of weeks ago
at the National
Conservatism Conference
and Thiel spoke-
- Yeah.
and Ted Cruz and J.D. Vance.
It was a really great,
sort of powerhouse event.
And what they were really
trying to do there is figure out
how conservatism, in many ways,
can link back to all the
stuff we're talking about here
and link back to belief,
but then will there be
room for the outsiders,
for the people that are not
religious or for the gay people?
And there was a very, I think
the panel of the entire thing
was me and Douglas Murray,
we both happened to be gay,
speaking with Sohrab Ahmari,
who of course,
I'm sure you know,
Catholic thinker and author-
- Yeah.
- and Yoram Hazony,
Orthodox Jew,
trying to figure out,
can this thing fit?
Can we fit this thing together?
Now, I'm curious because
you're talking about faith
and all of this stuff,
your son, Spencer,
who's a good friend of mine,
who I think is like
one of the all-stars
of like the future
conservative movement-
- Absolutely.
- he happens to be gay,
it does not matter to me,
but as you're
talking about this,
as a father and then as
a political communicator,
how do you piece all
of this stuff together?
I know you guys have discussed
it publicly once or twice-
- Yeah, yeah, no, and my opinion
of this has never changed.
(Andrew laughs)
My father explained
this to me once
when we went to a party
when I was a little kid
and I saw a gay couple
and he explained it to me
and in those days,
saying that this was a
psychological disorder
was the liberal point of view.
That was the accepting
point of view.
And that's what he said to me.
And I remember
shrugging, saying,
"They're not hurting anybody."
(Dave and Andrew laughs)
And I still feel that
way, but I actually,
I feel that God is
a lot more hilarious
and creative than
we think he is.
And a lot of the kind
of pinched, mean,
you know, like you have to
do what I tell you to do,
is not really in the gospels.
And I know people get so
ticked at me when I say this,
but it really isn't.
And there's a much greater sense
of like abundance of beauty
and abundance of creation.
I think we need, it is,
it helps political people
to talk about a vertical
world of good and evil.
But in fact, there
is good and evil.
There is such a thing
as good and evil,
and there is that vertical axis.
But there's also
a horizontal axis
of centrality and outwardness.
And I, for instance,
I'm an artist.
I've lived my life as
a novelist and artist.
I'm not at the center.
You know, if your a
garbage man disappeared,
you would miss him
way, way, way
(Dave laughs)
before you missed me.
I'm here to serve him.
I'm here to entertain
him, to beautify his life,
to beautify the life
of ordinary people
or central people,
I should call them,
'cause they're not ordinary,
but central people.
And I feel this way
about sexuality too.
I think the center of human life
is a man and a woman
having children.
I think if without that,
you know, forgive me,
but without that, you
don't have a world.
You don't have that
central kind of polarity.
- Yeah, I get it.
I don't disagree.
- That human beings, yeah.
- I don't disagree.
- Right.
But just because something
is not at that center,
doesn't mean it's not beautiful.
And it doesn't mean it's
not part of creation.
And this is one of the things,
I mean, you look around.
One of the things
about Spencer's,
I knew when he was three
years old, I started to think,
"Ah, this kid could
very well be gay,
and I'm going to
teach him to be a man
because I think he
should be a man."
And I hope I did,
and I think I actually
believe he's a wonderful man.
He's a terrific man,
but that was who he was,
and that was clearly who
he had been born to be.
And so I think that like
a little bit of just,
you know, I really do believe
that Jesus wants us
to blow the hinges
off the doors of our hearts.
You know, just like, okay,
are you hurting anybody?
Are you preaching evil?
Are you're polluting us?
Are you corrupting us?
Or are you living in love and
going forward with whatever,
you know, you have
problems, I have problems,
all God's children got problems.
You know, that's really
the thing that unites us.
And so I think if we could
remember as conservatives
that there is this
horizontal axis
and we have a
right to prioritize
mommy and daddy families,
we have a right to say,
"Yes, that's what's at
the center, we need them,"
just like we have a right to
prioritize working people,
people who do certain
things, doctors,
things that are essential
to human life.
But that does not mean we
should not live in love
and appreciate the beauty
of other kinds of things
that are not central, like art.
Again, you know, if the
great violinist disappears,
you're gonna miss
your carpenter.
You're gonna miss the lady
who was cleaning your house
before you miss the
great violinist.
He's not at the center of
things, but he's beautiful.
He makes life worth
living, you know?
And I just, that is the
attitude that I really do have.
That's not a put on attitude,
it's not a philosophy.
That's the way I actually feel.
You know, I feel that life
is a lot more beautiful
when you live that way, and it
makes evil putrid, you know?
When you see how beautiful
most people are, really,
and most relationships are.
And then when somebody
comes along and says,
"Oh, you should judge
that person by the
color of his skin."
It is like a rank
smell. (laughs)
And so we need to,
I think conservatives
need to live a little bit.
And you know what the
funny thing is, Dave?
You know, as Spencer is engaged
to Josh, this wonderful guy,
and he had a house party.
- Yup, yup.
- So I go to the house
party and there's,
you know, crazy gay
people coming in.
There's, Josh's relatives
were all these kind of down-home
Americans from the Midwest,
and then there's all The Daily
Wire guys were all these,
you know, kind of some
cigar-smoking guy,
and they're all
right-wing Republicans.
Every one of them-
- No, they can't.
- is like a
right-wing Republican.
And I just thought, "You
know, we live like this.
Why shouldn't we
think like this?"
They don't believe
what you don't believe.
If we love, some of these
people who were there
believe in a
philosophical conversation
that gay marriage is the
end of Western civilization
as we know it, but
they were there.
Why? Because they love Spencer.
They love Josh.
They want them to be happy.
I think like, "Well, why not
make that your philosophy?"
You know, why not make the love,
put the love at the
center of your philosophy
and stop sitting around in
your head with ideas that,
you know, may sound good
and may fit together,
but actually, you're
not expressing
that other part of yourself.
- Well, that's the funny part
because it's always
the anonymous
Twitter and YouTube commentators
telling me how much you
scary conservatives hate me.
Meanwhile, we're
breaking bread together
and having a hell of a time.
(Andrew laughs)
And they're the ones in the
name of tolerance and diversity,
telling me how much you hate me.
It's quite extraordinary.
- It's amazing.
- You kind of gotta
get a credit, you know?
(Andrew laughs)
- Yes, they're very
good at what they do.
And to be fair, they own so
much communication territory.
It's a little easier for
them than it is for us.
We're always kind of struggling
to get our voices heard.
- Yeah, so as long as
we're talking about art,
I've got your new book here.
And, you know, people in our
world, in the political world,
I don't think everyone knows
that you've been a novelist
for decades at this point.
(Andrew laughs)
How many books have you written?
- It's over 30.
Yeah, I've lost track.
- I mean, that's, as someone
that just finished my second,
I don't know how you've
possibly written 30.
(Andrew laughs)
It's pretty extreme.
And you're writing novels also.
So I mean like-
- Yes.
- this is heavy-duty stuff.
You write a lot of mysteries.
How did you get
interested in all of this?
And to some of the stuff,
that stuff that you
bring to the novels,
does that move into the
way you approach politics
and culture and all that?
- Yeah, I mean, a
novel comes out of you.
It's a vision, you know?
And I loved,
you know, when I was a kid,
I didn't really have
any male role models
and I was desperate
to find them.
And I found them in writers
and most of them were
tough guy writers,
guys like Ernest Hemingway.
But essentially, the
ones I really loved
were the mystery, the
tough guy mystery writer.
So Dashiell Hammett, and
especially Raymond Chandler
with his kind of
knight-like hero who,
he sat down these mean streets,
a man must go who
is not himself mean.
And that's where we get the
phrase, down these mean streets.
And I just loved that idea
that the world was corrupt,
but you were gonna walk
through it just like this.
You know, just with
your eyes on the right.
And you were gonna
do that right.
As a little kid, I just
thought that's who I wanna be.
And so those were the books
that kind of inspired me.
And as I became a writer,
I kind of lost the track for
a while in my troubled youth.
But when I straightened
my head out,
I kind of came back to that
and I consider myself as good
as any mystery writer alive,
and if I may plug the book-
- Yeah.
- Buy this book.
- We'll both hold the book
at the exact same time.
- Yes. Yes.
Because I will tell you, I
had this book in my mind for,
I have the last scene of this
book in my mind for 25 years.
- Wow.
- And I could not
build the story to get
to that last scene.
And I love Christmas,
and I always wanted to
write a Christmas story,
and I always thought
the problem with most
Christmas stories are bad.
You know, really only
"A Christmas Carol"
and it is a wonderful life
or good Christmas stories.
And the reason most
of them are bad
is they're about you finding
something that you want.
Finding love, or finding a home,
or finding mom and
dad or whatever.
But Christmas is actually about
sacrifice and about change.
It's about what the
Bible, they call metanoia,
which is turning around
and giving something away.
You know, giving something
that you love away
in order to be free.
And so I wanted to
write that story
and I had the scene in my mind,
and I couldn't build a story
that got honestly to that scene.
So my friend Otto
Penzler who is the great,
he is the greatest
American mystery editor.
And we were in the pandemic
and he was locked down
in the middle of nowhere.
He's like down in Connecticut,
and he called me up and we were
having these conversations,
you know, I was kind
of keeping him company.
And he said, "When are you
gonna write a Christmas book?"
And I said, "Yeah."
I said, "Would you publish it?"
And he said, "Oh yeah, I'll
publish a Christmas book."
So I thought I gotta
figure this book out.
And I took two long walks.
And at the end of the long
walk, this little bell went off,
and I thought,
"That's the story."
And it came out, I'm so happy
with the way it came out.
It's been, it was
number 12 on Audible,
and it was number 30 on Amazon.
And the reviews have
just been ecstatic.
I mean, people are
just like on the site,
not people I know, they're
just raving about it.
And I have to say.
I don't wanna oversell it,
but I have to say this.
(Dave laughs)
We need, we need quality art-
- Yes, we need stories.
- On our side, you know?
- Yeah.
- Yes.
Because we have so
much right-wing can't
and so much kind of foundering
political propaganda
and not enough, like
just good stories
that are imbued with
our view of life,
which is the kind
of view of life
that you and I have
just been talking about
through this whole interview.
And I will stand by this book.
I do not believe anyone is
gonna read this book and say,
"Wow, I got ripped off."
I think you're
gonna read this book
and it just is a really
good Christmas story.
- Well, here's my
commitment to you.
I only got the book yesterday,
so I have not read it yet,
but I'm hopping on
a plane tomorrow,
tomorrow, two days
to go to Nashville,
and I'm gonna have
dinner with your son,
and I do most of my reading
on the plane-
- Excellent.
- so I will start the book.
I'm curious, you know, as
someone that's only written
or has only written
two nonfiction books,
when you're writing a mystery,
do you have a freaking big
whiteboard in front of you,
really plotting all
the twists and turns?
Or are you just
kind of figure it,
you like know where
you're going at the end
and you just figure
it out as you go?
- No, there are some
writers who actually,
Ruth Rendell was one of them
who actually right off
the top of their heads.
I outline everything.
And sometimes the outline
changes along the way.
You know, when I see
that a character won't do
what I wanted him to do,
I have to change the plot to
accommodate the character.
But if I know where I'm going,
then I get the joy of writing.
I hate outlining by the way,
and it takes me weeks to do it,
and it's just dull.
It's the only part of my
job I really find dull,
but then I'm free to just
write the book and create it,
and that's what I
really wanna be doing.
So it's much easier that way.
It always amazed me,
but one of the thing about
writers who don't outline,
is they tend to write the
same two or three books
over and over again.
And Ruth Rendell is
a wonderful writer,
but after you've read, I
don't know, five of her books,
you've kind of read
her books, and like,
I don't mean to knock
her 'cause she is,
some of her books
are just wonderful,
especially her
Barbara Vine books,
but I find if I
outline, I can say,
"Oh, I've done this before,"
and throw it away and
do something fresh
and new, you know?
And that's really
been helpful to me
and I like doing it that way.
If you read this, if you
do read it on the plane,
you know, I trust
you, I believe you.
(Dave drowns out Andrew)
- I will, I will.
- But I hope you will say
something online if you like it.
(Dave laughs)
- I will.
(Andrew laughs)
- I promise you, you will get,
if it's good, you will get the
Dave Rubin comment somewhere-
- 'Cause for some reason-
- on Amazon.
- for some reason, people
believe what you say. (laughs)
- I'm wondering about it myself.
Listen, before I let you go,
anything else on your mind?
I kind of didn't wanna do
too much of the
day-to-day politics.
This is exactly-
- Yeah.
- what I wanted to do with you,
because I feel like everyone's
just going nuts with politics
and COVID and everything else.
- Yup.
- Is there anything else that's
just sort of been thinking,
you know, you moved,
life seems pretty good,
you got a new book out, you
seem happy, anything else?
- It's a wonderful time for me,
and I'm very grateful
to have come this far
and actually be
doing what I'm doing
and loving the people around me
and loving the things
that I'm doing is really,
it really is great.
And yeah, the only
thing I would say is,
I would just reiterate what
I said before, you know?
That like we must,
we cannot be afraid.
Almost everything the left does
is geared toward
making us afraid.
You know, wear a mask, get
a vaccine, wear two masks,
wear six masks, you know?
Put a mask on your children,
give your children a vaccine.
Everything is
about being afraid.
And not only that, but
they've made fear a virtue.
What do you mean you're not
afraid of climate change?
Are you a denier?
You must be a denier.
You know, everything
is about fear.
And the reason for that,
you know, C.S. Lewis, the
great Christian apologist,
he wrote about this.
He said that the devil wants
you to be afraid because fear,
courage is the
centerpiece of all virtue.
You cannot be virtuous
without courage.
And this is a moment,
I won't lie, this is
one of the worst moments
in American culture
I have ever seen.
Our art stinks,
our music stinks,
our movie stinks, our TV stinks,
most, except for mine, many
of our novel stink. (laughs)
But, and I think
the reason for that
is we have gutted
our belief system
of everything worthwhile, and
so people can't create art.
If we are not afraid,
we will pass through
this into a better time.
There is simply no question.
If we're afraid,
and if we surrender,
and if we say yes or no,
okay, I won't say anything.
Please don't call me racist.
If we keep apologizing,
like so much of
these canceled fools,
they cancel you for
something and they say,
"Oh, I'm so sorry, I
wanna be a better person."
And then they just
devour you, you know?
It's like blood in the water.
I am actually very hopeful.
I think we have come to
the end of something.
And it's the end of
the post-war era,
it's the end of
a post-war order.
We need new ideas,
and I think there are people
out there who are coming,
Spencer, one of them coming
along with new ideas,
new ways of thinking
about things.
And I'm actually very hopeful,
but we have to start
with the courage
of all those people I was
talking about, who are central.
They have to have courage.
It can't just be
the outline heroes,
it's gotta be the people at
the center who starts to say,
"You know what? We're
gonna speak the truth.
Even if you torment us."
- Klavan you finish an interview
like you know where it's going,
just like a fine novelist would.
I look forward to
you having whiskey
and me having tequila in
person, one of these days,
probably not in this town.
- You got it.
(Andrew laughs)
You gotta get out of there
and I can't wait to see you.
I always, one thing I
hate about the media
is I only see my
friends on camera.
(Andrew laughs)
- The book is "When
Christmas Comes."
I'm gonna read it.
And I, you know
what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna read it.
And whether I love it or hate
it, or somewhere in between,
I will send you my
comment before I post it,
so that you can make-
- All right.
- your argument.
If I don't like it,
you can push back.
If I like it too much,
I know you wouldn't
want people to think
that I'm like doing
you a favor here,
so we'll figure it out.
(Andrew laughs)
- I know you'll tell the truth.
- Good seeing you, my friend.
- It's great to see you, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.